J'aimerais pouvoir revenir en arrière et jouer
contre l'Australie, vous savez, malheureusement,
il est comme si vous ne pouviez rien changer
sur Internet et ils le savent, mais ils
resteront encore longtemps dans le record,
mais c'est embarrassant, vous connaissez mon équipe,
vous savez qu'ils ont coupé  le cœur je sais qu'il
n'y a pas vraiment les compétences et
tout mais ils ont le courage Je
[Musique]
joue avec yan Cruyff de George Best J'ai
entraîné plusieurs équipes de l'Ouest Je sais
comment ça marche au plus haut niveau
ne le dis pas  moi que faire tu m'as amené
ici pour mettre la sensation TS gagnante n'interfère pas avec le
jeu de tir wallah la plus grande
seule mort au monde
wow c'est plutôt cool
Oh mon Dieu bravo
personne je viens de me chier d'accord sérieusement
[Musique]